und dann anfang der woche auch noch
ausgerechnet eine spitze des ex des
ex-außenministers ex-wirtschaftsminister
sex spd-chefs
zeitenwende heißt für einen politiker so
ziemlich das gegenteil von dem zu tun
was er normalerweise tut sprich
sozialdemokraten müssen waffen kaufen
grüne um fossile energie bitten und
liberale jeden tag schulden bewilligen
als ehemaliges kabinettsmitglied ließ
sich darüber munter scherzen als
aktuelles angeschlagenes nicht so sehr
vielleicht auch weil sigmar gabriel
spruch einen wahren kern hat und den
kern des ampel problems berührt
begeistert von sich selbst im eigenen
teamgeist wärmen gestartet ideologisches
musste zurückstehen hinter dem
unbedingten drang zu regieren
sein bei dem wir aufbrechen jetzt
beginnt die zeit der tat mit
pragmatismus und vor allen dingen auch
mit viel leidenschaft die scheint nun
ein halbes jahr später zunehmende
gereiztheit gewichen jüngstes beispiel
die über gewinn steuer eine debatte
selbst entfacht ich hoffe dass der
vorschlag dieser sogenannten über gewinn
steuer damit vom tisch ist ich kann sie
nicht vom tisch nehme ich halte sie für
eine gute idee das ziel eine grüne
moderne gerechte gesellschaft zum
schwarze null tarif war ohnehin höchst
ambitioniert jetzt im stress des der
krisen zeigt sich umso mehr wie
spektakulär man daran scheitern kann
denn die idee zu über gewinn steuer war
nur die folge des ersten fehlschlags des
tank rabatt der nicht grün ist nicht
gerecht nicht gratis das problem eben
bei dieser beschlussfassung war dass man
auf der einen seite versucht jedem der
drei partner einen eigenständigen
spielraum in seinen kernbereichen in
seinem kern politikbereichen zu gewähren
auf der anderen seite aber im
regierungsalltag doch wieder auf
kompromisse angewiesen ist und erst
recht dann in krisen auf ad hoc
kompromisse am ende könnte das drohen
dass wir immer wieder zu unstimmigkeiten
was die ausführung von bestimmten
vorhaben betrifft kommen reißen die
ideologischen gräben also dauerhaft neu
auf zumindest zeigt sich selbst wenn die
frontfigur in harmonie darbieten nehmen
die spannungen intern bei immer mehr
themen zu
so forderte sie etwa die fdp dürfe nicht
wieder bremsen beim schutz vor corona im
herbst dieser hinweis sei unwürdig
antwortet er und empfiehlt den grünen
seinerseits ihre politiker fakten zu
gründen statt auf angst das problem als
moderieren der schlichter fällt er
weitgehend aus weil er selbst am meisten
unter druck steht seit monaten schon
nicht teile die kritik dass zu wenig und
zu spät geliefert wird scholz dilemma
seine eigene partei fremdelt am meisten
mit dem was die angekündigte zeitenwende
eigentlich meint auch die anderen haben
mühe ihre parteien mit dem gemeinsamen
projekt zu versöhnen allerdings und das
könnte sich zum problem auswachsen nicht
alle gleich vielen
spd und fdp wurden schon ordentlich
abgestraft bei den landtagswahlen und im
bundestrend auch nur die grünen
erscheinen als hätten sie mit all dem
nichts zu tun bei den anderen wächst
internet deshalb der grau nach außen
derweil noch jedenfalls durch alter ab
wir werden die nächsten dreieinhalb
jahre in dieser legislatur noch daran
arbeiten können auch die entsprechende
zustimmung für unsere politik zu
bekommen jeder partner auch in dem maße
wie er es verdient hat wenn man jetzt
sozusagen immer nur schaut was ist
gerade populär dann macht man politik im
nebel und das darf man nicht tun man
muss wirklich auf sicht fahren und weit
schauen weit über den horizont hinaus
und das gilt für diese schwerwiegende
entscheidung die wir treffen mussten das
scheint im nachhinein durchaus weitsicht
dicht dass man sich eines mit
hineingeschrieben hat in den
koalitionsvertrag die zuversicht dass
dies gemeinsam gelingen kann schwarz auf
weiß gleich am anfang man kann nie
wissen
[Musik]